[Music]
it has been known for some time that the
science fiction epic dune will get a
sequel after the movie was released last
september and received mostly positive
reviews director danny will never
revealed in an interview with collider
that the script is already as good as
finished that's an amazing pace because
the sequel has been in the works for a
while but few would have thought that
the script would be ready so quickly the
director is aware of the enormous
pressure and is concentrating a hundred
percent on dune part 2 which will follow
on directly from the first part shooting
is scheduled to begin this year in late
summer so that the planned start date of
october 20th 2023 is not in jeopardy the
left nevertheless also lets slip
something about a potential dune 3 which
would then be based on the book dune
messiah since the story of the first
book by frank herbert will be concluded
after the second movie accordingly he
would like to complete the story of
paula traders however each movie is a
proverbial monster in terms of scope and
effort which is why he's taking one step
at a time should the movie then be
relatively well received at the box
office it is pretty safe to assume that
warner brothers will then complete the
story in any case we are already looking
forward to dune part 2 which is
scheduled to be released on october 20th
2023
the hype around the obi-wan kenobi
series on disney plus is getting bigger
and bigger just last week disney
released the first trailer and this week
there is news again it's about darth
maul the infamous sith lord who
supposedly passed away at the end of
star wars the phantom menace but as we
found out later that wasn't the case he
led a life as a gangster boss after that
and at the end of solo star wars story
he appeared as the boss of the crimson
dawn syndicate his goal to finally exert
revenge on obi-wan because of this many
fans have been looking forward to an
appearance by darth maul in the obi-wan
series but the hollywood reporter seems
to have bad news according to a report
actor ray parker was prepared for return
and was rumored to be on set depending
on the source there's even talk that
darth maul should have been the main
antagonist however this all has been
denied by lucasfilm so far allegedly
john favreau and dave filoni are the
leading hats behind the decision to ban
the villain completely from the series
in this context another rumor is also
circulating which is that lucasfilm
producer filoni preferred to have darth
vader in the original role of darth maul
one indication of this is an interview
by lucas film president kathleen kennedy
in which she confirms that screenwriter
jlb herald will be revising the script
in the end we do get a popular character
back with hayden christians and as darth
vader but still some star wars fans were
hoping for some connection to darth maul
perhaps we can expect one or two more
surprises there is still little time for
further announcements before the series
starts streaming on disney plus may 25th
2022
after a long dry spell the production of
deadpool 3 seems to be moving forward at
the moment they seem to be looking for
director and it looks like the
negotiations are already close to being
concluded this talk of director sean
levi who could already score by working
with rattles on his movie free guy and
the atom project deadpool 3 would then
be the third collaboration between the
two and moreover levi would also be the
third director to direct a deadpool
movie after the first came from tim
miller and the second from david lych
the screenplay on the other hand is said
to be written by red reese and paul
ronik both of whom were also involved in
the first two movies currently they are
working together with lead actor ryan
reynolds on the completion of the new
script to what extent deadpool 3 will
differ from its two predecessors due to
its affiliation with disney remains to
be seen unfortunately an exact start
date is not yet known
recently star trek fans have been
getting their money's worth paramount
announced the signing of actor paul
wesley for its star trek strange new
world series he will play the character
of captain kirk making him the third
actor after william shatner and chris
fine to take on the iconic role the 39
year old wesley is best known for his
numerous appearances and vampire diaries
and has already been allowed to pose for
photo info costume but wesley won't be
there from the beginning because the
first season of this series which starts
in may will not feature his character
james t kirk at all the cast also
includes ethan peck as spock jess bush
as christine chappelle rebecca romine as
una chin rally and of course anson mound
as christopher pike the acting captain
of the uss enterprise in addition the
official star trek twitter channel
recently released a trailer that gives
us our first exciting look at the series
star trek strange new worlds will be
released on paramount plus may 5th 2022
where and when exactly you can watch
this series in a country without access
to the streaming service is not yet
known
to coincide with national panda day
dreamworks on netflix announced last
wednesday the production of a new kung
fu panda series the project titled the
dragonite was directly paced with new
images it was also announced that actor
jack blackwell once again dubbed the
popular panda poe the comment is of
course once again about setpo who has to
leave his home in search of justice and
meet an english night named wandering
blade on his journey the two eventually
travel on together to save the world
from destructive power of four magical
weapons unfortunately there is no exact
date yet though black revealed that it
should be as early as this july we'll
keep you posted on further news in any
case
we've already known since last month
that dakota johnson will play the lead
role in sony's madame web adaption
now we can already look forward to a new
face because 24 year old sydney sweeney
has joined the cast so far we know her
from various smaller appearances as well
as her role on the hbo hit show euphoria
where she plays the important character
cassie alongside costa zendaya since
2019. who exactly she embodies in madame
web is currently still the subject of
speculation one possibility would be the
character black cat a battle-hardened
villain who makes the life difficult for
the main character she's also a master
manipulator and made her first
appearance in the marvel comics in 1979
also the role of silver sable is a
possibility who comes across as a badass
mercenary with long wide hair she's not
a real superhero but a virtue also in
the field of hand-to-hand combat
firearms and espionage and even made an
appearance in the 2018 playstation game
marvel spider-man both theories seem
plausible but of course nothing is
confirmed yet in any case we'll keep you
posted on more news from sony's madame
web unfortunately a release date is not
yet known
everyone knows the movies of the
american film distributor metra golden
meyer or mgm for short the inventory of
the movie giant includes almost 4 000
movies and 17 000 tv series but mgm's
most prominent brand is probably james
bond interest in acquisition of mgm by
amazon had been under discussion since
early summer 2021 and now the 8.45
billion dollar deal has been finalized
the last hurdle was the concerns of the
european union which have been cleared
at least from a competition law
perspective in the long run this means
that amazon prime video users can expect
a significant increase in the streaming
catalog above all it is considered
likely that amazon will continue to
develop the james bond franchise and
perhaps even build a kind of universe of
its own around the dublo agent though
these are only rumors so far either way
prime users should keep their eyes open
for new movies and series in the near
future
fans of the netflix series the umbrella
academy have been waiting for new
episodes since the release of season 2
and the gigantic cliffhanger at the end
since summer 2020. therefore we are
pleased to announce that the responsible
parties have finally revealed the new
start of season 3 in connection with a
teaser particularly in focus will be the
sparrows consisting of seven members and
assembled by sir reginald hargreaves who
confront the previous heroes the six
human members of the sparrows are marcus
alfonso faye jaime sloane and an
alternate version of venn in addition
the squad is joined by sparrow number
seven a mysterious telekinetic cube
named christopher netflix will release
the first episode of the umbrella
academy season 3 on june 22nd 2022 but
we definitely expect a proper trailer
before
we hope you enjoyed this week's news
episode in case you missed it be sure to
check out the new trailer from miss
marvel on a channel if you're more
interested in the talking hedgehog we
can recommend you the latest trailer of
sonic the hedgehog 2 which you can also
find on our channel
[Music]
foreign
[Music]